shomenuchi Samuel all the water I
schöner cheats on your own what they
want this is the dominant side of the
sake of form from show energy here I
come in exactly like an EVO at this
point the forms are not sting gwa
sharable so I driving down to this
position however here in the OC call me
was on the pinning techniques I'm not
able to get him down this is a guy who
wants to come right back up into me so I
able to hold him here he's not going to
get up and just can't quite get him down
I step inside leg in and slide elbow to
elbow it's important here that I keep
the tip of my elbow holding him down so
see if my mother el gym I always keep it
from coming up and my elbow were here
he'd be able easily come up into me
while I'm doing this they said this hand
up here for the Sun Kil so my hands
really close to being able to grab him
here as I pop off his elbow he'll rot
and I come in with the attiny and the
Sun two at the same time here as he
falls back I Drive you down dropping the
inside he right next to his head here I
have a lot of leverage during this sun
filled the other hand comes across him
grabs and locks it to my stomach I
dropped this knee looking forced him to
hook his shoulder and his wrist with the
Sun gear one more time is Pete I
shonichi sankyo or multi water